last week the globe theater in london
announced a new play called i joan about
the legendary 15th century saint joan of
arc but this play is not really about
joan of arc the actual historical person
who led a french army to major military
victories before being captured and
burned alive at the stake at the age of
19.
this play is about a fictionalized
non-binary version of the saint the
globe explained in an announcement on
twitter um
quote our new play i jones shows joan as
a legendary leader who uses the pronouns
they them we are not the first to
present joan in this way and we will not
be the last we can't wait to share this
production with everyone and discover
this cultural icon
so first of all shouldn't the play be
called we joan if it's they them
pronouns but of course grammatical
consistency is the least of the problems
that we have here uh accompanying the
announcement is a promotional image
showing joan of arc frail dirty sullen
and wearing a chest binder on their
website the globe continues its defense
of the portrayal claiming quote we are
not the first to present joan in this
way and we will not be the last
regarding the use of pronouns they to
refer to a singular person has been
traced by the oxford english dictionary
to as early as 1375 years before joan
was even born regardless theaters do not
deal with historical reality theaters
produce plays and in plays
anything can be possible
now it's true that they has often been
used
through the centuries to refer to a
singular person that's true but that's
only when you're talking about a
singular person in the abstract or
hypothetically or
if you don't know the individual sex so
for example
somebody cuts you off in traffic and all
you see is their back bumper and you
don't know who it is you might remark
that they are an a-hole or if you're
more dedicated like me you might speed
up so you can get a good look at the
person and then cuss them out with more
specificity but if you're speaking about
a specific known individual the pronoun
they makes no sense and serves no
intelligible purpose
there is no precedent in the english
language or any other language of using
they to refer to a specific man or a
specific woman instead of just saying he
him her
or her
and
there is certainly no precedent of
individuals selecting their own pronouns
for themselves and demanding that others
abide by that preference there is no
precedent for that that has never
existed anywhere in the world and it
certainly did not exist in medieval
france
now the theater takes refuge in the fact
that theatrical productions don't have
to deal strictly with historical reality
and yes there is indeed a long tradition
of events and people from history being
partially or totally fictionalized for
the sake of telling a story but in this
case they're fictionalizing joan of arc
in a way that completely negates nearly
everything that made joan of arc
significant to begin with the whole
point of the joan of arc story the
reason she's remembered by history has
been revered down the centuries the
reason that she's a patron saint of
france the reason that she's beloved is
one of the great catholic saints
is that she did all that she did as a
woman
to erase her womanhood is to erase her
this really isn't very much different
from reimagining frederick douglass or
martin luther king jr as white men and
something tells me that this theater nor
any other theater in the world would be
quite so
artistically open-minded as to host a
stage production depicting a black civil
rights leader as a white dude
you know the appetite to fictionalize uh
history
the appetite for fictionalized
retellings of historical events
seems to be rather selective shall we
say well today's world is uh kind of a
scary one sometimes too many people
don't seem to care about the truth moral
standards have flown out the window and
i'd argue that it's all rooted in people
becoming less religious that's why it's
more important than ever that we take a
step back from all this craziness and
keep our relationship with god strong
and the best way to do that is by
praying every day with hallo hallo is
the number one christian prayer app in
the u.s it's like calm or head space but
rooted in catholic faith as opposed to
the religion of leftism hallo offers
over 5 000 audio guided prayers
meditations and christian music tracks
some of the most popular prayers include
the bible in a year with five with
father mike schmitz uh minute
meditations and meditations for sleep as
well i also have prayers for kids and so
much more hallow helps me find peace and
calm throughout the day helps me sleep
better too lower my anxiety levels and
teach my kids not to be terrible humans
which is also an important part of this
let hallow help you find your peace and
strength throughout your day and also
strengthen your faith go to hello.com
matt walsh or text pray to
and get an 1-855-944-5684 three-month
free trial during which you'll have
access to all 5000 plus meditations
impaired that's hallow.com matt walsh or
text pray to 1-855-944-5684
for three months free reclaim your peace
in this crazy world download hallow
today but the greater problem is that
the people pushing this stuff
aren't actually willing to admit that
their fictionalization is merely a
fictionalization
over the past few days various academics
and historians have come out of the
woodwork to try and vindicate the
queerified joan of arc the gay news site
pink news featured an article written by
alleged historian florence scott
claiming that quote gendering joan of
arc isn't that straightforward
she writes quote
joan is a particularly elusive and
complicated historical figure we cannot
possibly access joan's understanding of
her own gender or how she related to the
gender roles of her day we can only look
at the available source material and
interpret how she expressed herself
the picture is complex
gender as something that is constructed
evolves over time that means any role we
ascribe to a historical figure man woman
or non-binary is anachronistic muddied
by modern conceptions of gender that
doesn't mean we can't relate to jones
experience of gender just that there's a
whole spectrum of ways to relate women
have a right to be inspired by joan as a
strong woman acting in defiance of a
patriarchal society but those of us who
are queer or non-binary
should also be able to see ourselves
reflected in her transgression of gender
roles and refusal to conform in taking
such inspiration from medieval figures
we need to be aware we are placing our
modern experiences and values on someone
who didn't share them whether we
conceive of joan as a woman non-binary
or even trans masculine and i think all
three are valid historical readings we
must remember that we cannot define her
we can only interpret her
well actually no we we can define her we
can define her in many ways okay define
means like if someone says who is joan
of arc or who was joan of arc we can
give an answer to that question we can
define her
we could say that she was born in france
we can say that she was martyred on may
30th 1431. we can say many objective
things about who she was and what she
did in between those dates we can say
that she was a human being and we can
say
that she was a woman
there is nothing complicated about any
of that
but as always the mo of the lgbt
propagandist
is to make murky even the clearest water
it is to create fog and confusion
wherever they find clarity
it is to unload a dump truck full of
meaningless jargon right into the middle
of every conversation
and it's also to rewrite not only our
current day reality
but history as well
and that effort to rewrite history is
now in full swing
over the last few days other academics
and historians have come out to argue
that joan of arc you know may not have
been non-binary but she was at least
non-binary adjacent or maybe she was
non-binary because this is how it goes
right first they first they say oh no
we're not claiming that non-bi that uh
joan of arc was actually non-binary oh
no actually we are claiming that
how quickly we make that transition
and not satisfied to simply desecrate
joan of arc's memory by trying to
posthumously recruit her into the lgbt
cult they've now moved on to other
historical figures
because this is the other thing that we
know the left always does right they
always double down
and so when they come along and say
where to portray joan of arc is
non-binary people are upset about that
their response isn't to back off it's to
say oh you know what just because you're
saying that not only was was joan of arc
non-binary but all these other
historical figures were too
the daily mail reports an academic
writing for the shakespeare's globe
theater has argued that queen elizabeth
the first may have been non-binary too
in an essay on the globe's website trans
awareness trainer dr kit hayaman
or i am
[Music]
that's not really what's important
what's important is trans awareness
trainer is a job title
and this person referred to the virgin
queen with they them pronouns saying
elizabeth the first described themself
regularly in speeches as king queen and
prince
the essay was published on monday august
8th and was published in defense of the
portrayal and said that the common
portrayal of the story as pragmatic
gender non-conformity in a patriarchal
world denies historical existences of
trans experience
the leads based dr haym whose pronouns
are they them or he him compared queen
elizabeth the first to 10th century
english ruler ethel fled lady of the
mercians who ruled murcia what is now
approximately the west midlands after
the death of her husband dr hayam said
ethelfled was later described as
conducting armies as if she had changed
her sex to take on a male-coded military
which was in some sense for ethel fled
to become male the writer and academic
says elizabeth first chose to
strategically emphasize their female
identity or their male
monarchical role at different points
now essentially what just to
clarify as much as we possibly can
what these academics are arguing is that
because these women of history
did things not traditionally associated
with women
or not traditionally expected of women
they must not have been women
as always the trans cult works to
rigidly and fanatically reinforce
the very gender binary that they pretend
to be breaking down
in their world it's
impossible that a woman might simply
elect to do masculine things
because if a woman does act in such a
way then she's a man
or at least she's non-binary
either way to sacrifice her femininity
even to the smallest degree is according
to trans activists to sacrifice her very
womanhood
now we can easily see
why they're so desperate to find
historical analogs for all of the gender
identities they've made up over the past
12 seconds
they're desperate because they claim
they didn't make any of this up
they claim that
people are born trans born non-binary
that these identities are deeply
ingrained inside a person
and if that's their claim it becomes a
rather significant problem that these
deeply ingrained and inherent identities
never made an appearance anywhere on
earth for the whole history of the of
the human species up until just now
it's not just a problem
in fact history alone completely
delegitimizes their entire worldview
all of history testifies against them
their solution therefore is to retcon
their worldview back into history it's
to start draping rainbow flags over the
tombs of our ancestors
in some kind of perverse act of
ideological necrophilia they violate the
dead dragging them into their sexual
cult
their war on reality is not just
therefore happening in the present
it's also happening
all the more so in the past
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
that wall show if you did be sure to
subscribe to this youtube channel and
click the notification button to get
more content like this if you want to
watch or listen to the full show head to
dailywire.com and subscribe today you
can also listen to my podcast on spotify
apple podcast or wherever you get your
podcasts